the bark of the Daphne shrub also known
as lakhta has to be washed and then
boiled in order to make paper from it
when electricity came to this area
corner goo room was finally able to
purchase a boiler and shredder today he
has ten employees that collect and wash
the lock to bark the heavy work is done
by machines
the file now they could apply laminate
louder and I used to have to boil the
lock to bark using firewood and stamp on
it with our feet to soften it quite a
little bit ago nobody bought the
electricity comes from a small
hydroelectric power plant the government
has been promoting them in this mountain
region for years and giving loans to
entrepreneurs and farmers so they can
buy machines after the power plant was
installed and we got electricity I was
in a better position economically
Ponyboy had lower labor costs so I was
able to make a profit and I could even
save some money
Wynonna what he was was the unup owner
mountain range in the himalayas
overlooks the village of ghandruk which
lies at an elevation of 2,000 meters
this is where poor nagar room lives the
area has a lot of water so it makes
sense to install hydroelectric power
plants which are relatively easy to
build and are environmentally friendly
government support for the hydropower
projects has granted only to villages
that agreed to pitch in 10 years ago
Vidya vishwakarma helped to build this
power plant today she's the deputy
manager
the village meanwhile has nine of these
power plants each with a management
board and a manager they handle the
finances themselves
I saw a guy at the moment the plant is
self-sustaining the fee we get from our
customers helps us pay our staff and
it's enough to maintain the plant as
well the electricity from the hydropower
plant was also a blessing for Shanta
Maya guru who runs a bakery the mother
of two can now provide the entire
village with bread
how they tiny I was the first person to
open a bakery here for the past five
years she's been baking bread here her
brother works by her side she's already
managed to pay off the mixer in the oven
but if something breaks it can get
expensive it can be difficult if one of
the machines stops working then we have
to go all the way to Pokhara to have it
fixed fortunately she also earns money
from her small kiosk which is right next
to the bakery local people are her main
customers but tourists who come here to
go climbing in the Annapoorna mountains
sometimes shop here to the village of
ghandruk is home to about 5,200 people
the power plants have changed their
lives they now cook with electricity and
there are two telecommunications masts
in the village health care has also
improved recently I had dental treatment
which was only possible because the
medical station has electricity now
without electricity none of this would
exist everyone is making the most of it
nonetheless about 40% of the people in
the villages here still don't have
electricity Nepal has been working to
renew and expand the electricity grid
after a devastating earthquake destroyed
much of it four years ago hydroelectric
power is the linchpin of the
government's plan
a lot has changed for papermaker porno
guru he's even been able to open a shop
in Pokhara the second largest city in
Nepal this is where he sells his
untreated paper as well as products such
as Diaries and notebooks cards and
lampshades
this income made it possible for the
widower to raise his two children and
send them to school his daughter now
lives in Pokhara and also works in the
shop poor nagar rome stops by at least
once a week
he's planning to expand his business
obese young mangonia your I lived in
doctor and Himalayan nettle could be
processed in the same facility so I'm
thinking of expanding and processing
nettles to make fabric poor Nagar room
has big plans for the future but he
doesn't want to move to the city
full-time the mountains are his home